on Thursday Madison Square Garden
company boss James Dolan announced that
the Radio City Rockettes had agreed to
perform at the Trump inauguration and a
bunch of the Rockettes sort of went off
their rockers one Rockette wrote quote I
usually don't use social media to make a
political stand but I feel overwhelmed
with motion finding out that it has been
decided for us that Rockettes will be
performing at the presidential
inauguration makes me feel embarrassed
and disappointed the women I work with
our intelligence are full of love and
the decision of performing for a man
that stands for everything we're against
is appalling I am speaking for just
myself but please know after we found
out this news we have been performing
with tears in our eyes and heavy hearts
which makes this show really crappy we
will not be forced hashtag not my
president George Takei who's an ardent
Trump opponent and Sulu of course from
the old Star Trek he tweeted in their
support and here's what he tweeted the
members of the Rock Cats in the Mormon
Tabernacle are like all of us forced to
go along with something horrible they
didn't choose I mean like half the
country did actually choose Trump and
actually pretty much everybody chose to
live here and it's a peaceful transition
of power that happens every four years
but you know meanwhile Anthony Bourdain
has announced he won't eat at any
restaurant hosted at Trump Tower fashion
icon Andre Leon Talley has said he won't
dress Melania Trump any more artists
whose products hang him Ivanka Trump's
apartment have asked her to remove their
art they have not asked for her to give
back the money suddenly it seems the
left has discovered freedom of
association
after years of telling religious people
they had a moral and legal obligation to
throw out their religion and service
same-sex weddings and provide
contraception and fund abortion now the
left realizes the ability to pick and
choose those to whom you give your
services is actually kind of important
don't expect us to last of course
artists should be able to turn down
clients so should religious bakers but
you won't see left acknowledge that the
only freedom to turn down clients is the
freedom for leftist to turn down
conservative and religious clients not
the other way around
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
all right tons to get to here today on
the very last ben shapiro show broadcast
of the year and then we're on a long
break actually because we're out next
week for for christmas
cuz you christians and then we're we're
out the following week because of me
because i'm going on vacation with my
wife so it's gonna be a long break so
enjoy this one savor every last
delicious morsel of knowledge and
information of humor and insight that
comes to you courtesy of this right here
this big brain but first you have to say
hello to our advertisers over ring.com
so if you are concerned about burglary
III know I am actually my wife is kind
of paranoid about burglary we've had
some security issues in the past ring
calm make sure that you don't have a lot
of these security problems anymore
because most burglaries are not just
somebody breaking into your house they
usually happen when somebody rings the
doorbell and then they realize nobody's
home and then they break into your house
well the ring ring back home system it
has a camera on it they ring the
doorbell and you can pick up and say
that you're at home no matter where you
are you can see who's there without
actually being at home fantastic system
one of our advertisers on whom I
actually spend my own money for
additional product they have this ring
of security kept they're selling now
it's a ring video doorbell for the front
door a ring stick up cam the wireless
weatherproof HD camera and that keeps an
eye on other parts of your property and
you can install these things in minutes
they are very easy to install I've done
it myself and again we've used it all
the time it's it's Gregg's I have kids
at home and a nanny and I want to know
what's going on when somebody rings the
doorbell and that's what ring comm does
for me ring comm / Ben and you get 150
dollars off that ring of security kit
terrific product and make sure that you
go to ring comm / menus the / Ben's they
know that we sent you as well as you
getting the discount okay so the big
news today the big news today is that
Barack Obama ain't like them Jews he
he's not fond of the Jewish state he
thinks that the Jews are apparently
troublesome in the Middle East this is
nothing new
I'm old enough to remember when I
appeared on Fox News in 2014 and said
this was a Jew hating administration
because they were attempting to cut off
weapon supplies to Israel in the middle
of their war against Hamas well today
Obama has revived a in Egypt originally
Egypt pushed UN resolution that was
designed to undercut Israel's claims -
really
exist in the Middle East this this UN
resolution is now about to be voted on
at the UN Security Council and Barack
Obama is the guy who decided to bring it
to fruition because he signaled to
everybody that the United States would
abstain now the United States has always
had Israel's back at the UN Security
Council even during some of the even
during some of the early Obama years but
they no longer do and it's been clear
for a while that Obama despises Israel
and sees Israel as a as a moral and as a
foreign policy threat a regional threat
to peace in the Middle East he's
constantly been putting pressure on
Israel so this UN resolution draft and I
want to go through it because I think
that it's important to actually know
what people are talking about this draft
that's being circulated Obama has
basically said they're going to abstain
and it's very clear that they are that
they are interested in slapping Israel
as they leave that's that's the goal
here is to slap Israel as hard as they
can before they leave because Trump by
all indicators is going to be very
pro-israel coming in as ambassador to
Israel is great yesterday he pressured
Israel to act he pressured Egypt
apparently behind the scenes to withdraw
the resolution and then Obama apparently
went behind the scenes according to
Israel and pressured Venezuela and
Senegal and New Zealand to respond sir
the resolution in the Security Council
which demonstrates how disgusting they
are so here is what this draft
resolution says this is the draft that
was going around yesterday the Security
Council reaffirms that the establishment
by Israel of settlements in the
Palestinian territory occupied since
1967 including East Jerusalem has no
legal validity and constitutes a
flagrant violation under international
law and a major obstacle to the
achievement of the two-state solution
and a just lasting and comprehensive
peace reiterates their demand that
Israel immediately completely cease all
settlements activities in the occupied
Palestinian territory including East
Jerusalem and that it fully respects all
of its legal obligations in this regard
underlines will not recognize any
changes to the June 4th 1967 lines
including with regard to Jerusalem
other than those agreed by the parties
through negotiation so in other words
what they are saying here I mean this is
really quite disgusting what they're
saying here is that Israel has no claim
in East Jerusalem that's what they're
saying
ok East Jerusalem is the capital of
Israel Eastern West Jerusalem is one
unified city the holiest spot in Judaism
which predates Islam by solid 1500 years
the only reason that Muslims care about
Jerusalem is cuz the Jews did first
the only reason Christians care about
Jerusalem is cuz the Jews did first the
Jews were there first it is the center
of Jewish life it is the center of
Jewish thought it is the center of
Zionism it has long been the dream for
3,000 years it's been the dream to have
a Jewish capital in Jerusalem that was
that dream was fulfilled in 1967 after
Arabs attacked Israel and Israel
responded all of this resolution is
false so for example they say that these
are settlements in Palestinian territory
occupied since 67 there was no such
thing as Palestinian territory in 1967
you know why because Jordan was in
charge of Jerusalem Egypt was in charge
of the Gaza Strip okay there was no
Palestinian government there was no
Palestinian people all of this was a
fiction that was created in the
aftermath of 1948 the Palestine
Liberation Organization was created to
destroy Israel between 48 and 67 not to
liberate East Jerusalem but to liberate
Tel Aviv right to destroy Tel Aviv
that's why they were calling for the
liberation of Israel before Israel had
any control over East Jerusalem
whatsoever these are not Israeli
settlements in Palestinian territories
this is Israeli building in territories
that are disputed and those disputed
territories by the late Jordan doesn't
claim ownership of those territories
Israel took those territories annexed
them Jordan renounced all claims to
those territories in 1988 and the
Palestinians had no claim to those
territories before 1967 so the language
here doesn't even make any sense
plus it is always in a great irony of
history that the Arabs over and over and
over rejected Israeli peace deals
rejected UN Partition plans and then
claimed that those lines should be the
final partition plan lines even after
they rejected them launched war against
Israel and lose that's not the way
international relations works beyond
that the idea that Jews building an
extra bathroom in East Jerusalem is a
threat to peace ignores the fact that
the goal of the Palestinian government
which is a unity government between the
terrorists from Hamas the terrorist
group Islamic Jihad and the terrorist
group the Palestinian Authority that
tripartite unity terrorist government
their goal forever has been the outright
genocide of Jews in the State of Israel
it's amazing to me that everybody always
talks about
how nasty the Jews are to the Israeli
Arabs by the way polls show Israeli
Arabs don't want to leave there's a
reason they're not moving to Palestinian
territories but what's amazing is the
focus on how Jews treat Arabs in Israel
how many Jews live in the Palestinian
territories like the ones that the
Palestinians actually administer in
control zero right the fact is that the
Palestinians would murder Jews who lived
there in fact after the Jews pulled out
of the Gaza Strip and then left all
their nice green houses and their nice
homes the Palestinians immediately came
in and burned them so what did what
actually the UN is calling for here is
to make all of these areas where Jews
live we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of Jews making them you'd and
Ryan ethnically cleansing the Jews
they're pushing them out killing them if
they stay that's what the UN is talking
about here when Barack Obama's going
right along with this because Barack
Obama sees Israel as the great threat he
has for his entire presidency he has for
his entire presidency here's a brief
history of Barack Obama on Israel and
his administration and I would remind
everybody that some of the commentators
that the left likes to quote people like
Jeffrey Goldberg at the Atlantic Jeffrey
Goldberg at the Atlantic was was openly
acknowledged inside the Obama White
House as a shill for President Obama in
2008 Jeffrey Goldberg actually wrote
before Obama was elected that any Jew
who had concerns about Obama being
anti-jewish and anti-israel was a racist
that guy is a respected voice on the
International Left and in America as
well by the way I quit side note here
Chuck Schumer has come out and he's
condemned this resolution he says that
that Obama should veto and this is the
same game that Chuck Schumer always
plays Chuck Schumer is both Jewish and
has a lot of Jewish constituents in New
York he's afraid of ticking them off but
he's playing good cop to Obama's bad cop
he's not gonna do anything what's he
gonna do he's not gonna join any
resolution to remove funding from the UN
Human Rights Commission or from the UN
Security Council but here's a brief
history for those who don't believe that
Obama has an anti-israel animus and
there are people on the Left who
actually believe this because they are
wilfully blinding themselves a BuzzFeed
bug BuzzFeed's Ben Smith came out today
and he says Israel is really taking an
openly anti Obama line is that where the
hell have you been for the last eight
years dude and where have you been we'll
go through the history in a second
Israel by the way has condemned this and
they say directly Obama and Kerry are
behind this shame
move against Israel at the UN the US
administration secretly cooked up with
the Palestinians in extreme anti-israel
resolution behind Israel's back which
would be a tailwind for terror and
boycotts and effectively make the
western wall occupied Palestinian
territory
which is true remember the western wall
which it's always funny people always
say that's the holiest site in Judaism
innocent okay the temple mount's is the
holiest site in Judaism the part that
the Islamic walk prevents Jews from
standing on that's the part that's the
holiest site the western wall is just
the outer border of that but in any case
the fact is that that you have Senator
Schumer urging this to be to be rejected
and he issued a strong statement saying
whatever anyone's views are sound
settlement anyone who cares about the
future of Israel and peace in the region
knows the UN with its one-sidedness is
exactly the wrong forum to bring about
peace yeah what's he gonna do about it
but here is a brief history of Obama on
Israel February 2008 Obama rips the
Likud Party even though we could isn't
in power June 2008 Obama says that
Jerusalem should be unified Jewish
territory in Israel he says that at
AIPAC and then within 24 hours reverses
himself and says that it shouldn't
remain undivided March 2009 now Obama's
president the Obama administration
rejoins the anti-semitic anti-jew UN
Human Rights Council foot well by the
way fully acknowledging int
anti-semitism they say sure the UN Human
Rights Council is anti-semitic but you
know no biggie May 2009 Obama tells
Netanyahu Prime Minister Netanyahu
settlements have to be stopped in order
for us to move forward with a peace deal
Netanyahu immediately announces a freeze
on settlements Obama rips Israel anyway
June 2009 Obama goes to Cairo says that
Israel was only founded because of the
Holocaust and then says the Palestinian
treatment at the hands of Jews is sort
of like the Holocaust July 2009 Obama
threatens openly to put daylight between
the United States and Israel September
2009 Obama says America does not accept
the legitimacy of continued Israeli
settlements as though the United States
really has a role to play here March
2010 VP Joe Biden visits Israel rips
Netanyahu again not just for settlements
but for what we call natural growth in
the settlements which means that you
want to build an extra bedroom because
you had an additional kid the Vice
President Joe Biden didn't want Israel
to be able to do that
Hillary apparently calls up Netanyahu
she's then Secretary of State she calls
up Netanyahu
and screams at him for an hour on the
phone later that month when Netanyahu
visits the White House Obama forces him
to leave through a side entrance June
2010 a US Defense source leaks and kills
Israel's plans to work with the Saudis
to strike the Iranian nuclear facilities
may 2011 the State Department labels
Jerusalem not a part of Israel my niece
who was born in Jerusalem currently her
passport just says Jerusalem they
refused to put Israel on it even though
Jerusalem is the eternal capital of the
Jewish people and again
the only reason anyone gives a rip about
Jerusalem is because of the Jews
November 2011 Nicolas Sarkozy is caught
on a hot mic telling Obama quote about
about Netanyahu I can't stand him he's a
liar and Obama says you're tired of him
what about me I have to deal with him
everyday December 2011 Israel compares
Israel to Iran Hillary compares Israel
to Iran February 2012 Secretary of
Defense Leon Panetta kills a potential
Israeli strike on Iran by talking about
it openly with the Washington Post March
2012 the Obama administration leaks
plans for Israel to work with Azerbaijan
to strike the Iranian nuclear facilities
killing the deal June 2012 the Obama
administration leaks that Israel was
behind the Stuxnet virus which was
designed to kill as Iran's nuclear
program December 2012 Hillary Clinton
says Israel Israel has a lack of empathy
for Palestinians and calls them an
oppressed people March 2013
oh but are you getting a message here
maybe Obama isn't fond of the Jewish
state getting that March 2013 Obama
forces Benjamin Netanyahu to call the
Islamist Turkish dictator type Recife
and the one to apologize for stopping a
terrorist flotilla from entering the
Gaza Strip and helping out Hamas June
2013 the Obama administration leaked
specific information regarding Israeli
arrow three anti-ballistic missile sites
that information had been classified
Obama had to apologize and blame it on
low-level staffers June 2014 three
teenaged three Jewish teens are
kidnapped including an American and they
are murdered by Hamas the Obama
administration calls on Israel for
restraint and says it will continue to
fund the Palestinian terrorist unity
government including Hamas August 2014
Obama personally steps in and attempts
to block shipments from the Pentagon of
weapons to Israel October 2014 Jeffrey
Goldberg
Lisa's an article quoting Obama
officials calling Prime Minister
Netanyahu a chicken bleep January 15th
Obama deployed 2015 Obama deploys his
campaign team to defeat Netanyahu in
Israel and finally of course Obama
attempts to sign the Serenity a nuclear
deal which endangers Israel's very
existence so yes this has been a long
time coming of course Obama on his way
out slaps Israel because he sees Israel
as a Western imperialist outpost in
historically Muslim land and he wants to
see it go down in flames while
simultaneously making Iran a regional
power there is no other reason to do
this
this resolution achieves the the desired
impact of allowing momentum to attempted
boycotts of Israel it achieves the
desired impact of providing a basis a
logical basis for Arabs to murder
innocent Jews it's disgusting on every
level and I have to make a statement
about the timing here the good news I
have to say God has a sense of humor so
Obama of course sponsors this thing and
pushes this thing right on the verge of
Hannukah Hannukah for those who don't
know the story of Hanukkah and survive
Hanukkah is about Antiochus who was a
Greek King and he had installed as the
head of the temple one of his emissaries
who proceeded to basically strip all of
the vestments from the temple and ship
them out who proceeded to tax the Jews
pretty harshly and also ban all
religious practice the Jews led a
rebellion against Antiochus in order to
take back the temple and in order to
restore Judaism to Jerusalem right the
day before we celebrate we have
modern-day antiochus's in the UN and
attempting to strip Jewish sovereignty
from Jerusalem strip it of its religious
character pretend that it has nothing to
do with Judaism and guess what this time
the Maccabees are in charge folks
okay the Jews are not giving up through
selamat the Israelis are not coming up
to rue Salaam and no matter what a bunch
of pathetic disgusting dictatorships I
mean it's it's Senegal and in Venezuela
sponsoring this thing Venezuela they're
literally shooting dogs in the streets
to eat them because it is a socialist
dictatorship then Senegal right now is
threatening openly to invade its
neighbor does the UN Security Council do
anything about that of course not
instead they look at this resolution
that is sponsored and they attempt to
push it against Israel don't worry God
stands with the Jews when it comes to
standing up for Judaism in Jerusalem and
Israel is not going to cave on anything
like this by the way for people who
claim that the UN has any moral
legitimacy all I can say is Lindsey
Graham is in favor of if this if this
resolution is passed with us abstention
and Lindsey Graham says that we should
withdraw all funding from the UN if
that's the result I'm in favor of the
resolution anything that results in
funding being withdrawn from the UN I
can live with the UN has always been a
jew-hating Bastion there 193 countries
in the UN well over 50 of them are
Muslim dictatorships that doesn't even
include all of the various foreign
dictatorships that ally with the Muslim
dictatorships border the Muslim
dictatorships or anti-semitic in their
own right like some of the countries of
Europe the UN Human Rights Council of
the first hundred and three resolutions
of the UN Human Rights Council 56 of
them were dedicated to ripping Israel
there are more there are more
resolutions in the UN against Israel
than against North Korea and Syria
combined in 2016 the fact that anybody
takes the UN seriously demonstrates what
a joke this is the same leftists who are
complaining about Trump threatening NATO
which I agree is a bad thing are
completely silent about the United
Nations which threatens sovereignty of
individual countries and interferes and
peace deals in order to boost the worst
people on planet earth Barack Obama his
administration is an anti-semitic
administration he cannot stand in favor
of Arab terror against Israelis and you
can't be silent when American Jews get
killed in Israel and for and for me not
to assume that there's an animus there
of course there's an animus there this
policy is anti-semitic this policy's
anti-israel it is dedicated to the
destruction of the Jewish state because
the same logic that says that this is
historically the Jerusalem is
historically not Jewish let me tell you
something if he's Jerusalem it doesn't
belong to the Jews neither does tel-aviv
I was like saying Washington DC doesn't
belong to the Americans
makes it very difficult to make the case
that podunk Iowa does if Washington DC
doesn't so that's what's going on over
all this by the way and I should mention
that it is amazing where the UN decides
to put his focus it's their slaughter
occurring in Syria and on the level of
hundreds of thousands of people no UN
resolutions on that because Russia will
veto anything that comes up Russia is
more strongly allied with Syria than the
United States
under Barack Obama's allied with Israel
which should tell you something in the
atrocities that are currently occurring
are unbelievable I mean and the fact
that that Barack Obama is providing
fodder to the worst people on earth it
shouldn't come as a shock but it is
morally shocking here's just an example
there's a video that came out yesterday
I'm gonna play it in a second I want to
wait to play this fruit for just a
second but I'm gonna show you the second
in a second a video showing fanatic
Muslim lecturing his kids about the
virtue of jihad and apparently this is
this is coming from Syria so these are
the people who the West is at war with
but Obama prefers to ignore that we'll
play that video in just a second but
first we have to say hello to a new
advertiser there's this podcast you
should take a listen to I love listening
to other podcasts and not just my own my
own
I actually don't listen to my own
frequently but I love listening to
podcasts one of the podcasts you should
definitely take a listen to is they've
started creating these entertainment
podcasts and there's one called terms
and it's really kind of fun it's it's a
fictional podcast you can get it at
iTunes stitcher laundry com wherever you
listen to podcasts and they have new
episodes every Monday it's a political
thriller basically it's really well
produced it's really fun to listen to
it's it's the the plot is is essentially
but America has voted in one of its most
controversial presidents and the
outgoing president attempts to hold on
to power so you can sort of see where
this is going but you really can't cuz
it's unpredictable and it's really good
direct listeners can subscribe at least
three times you know I think right now
if you if you are a direct listener and
you subscribe three times right now you
can you can get a discount if you have
to pay for it I don't think it's to pay
for actual I think this is free so new
episodes drop every Monday check that
out and it's it's called terms again the
the URL is smart URL dot IT slash terms
SP so that's a little bit complicated so
we'll say it one more time smart URL dot
IT slash terms P slash terms P okay so
its terms podcast that's what it's terms
P so go check it out subscribe comes out
every Monday and it's a really good
podcast really entertaining ok so I want
to play you this video to leave you with
a sense of just how morally perverse the
American left is the International Left
is here is
a here's a video of a fanatic Muslim
informing his children about what to do
when they are confronted with Westerners
he going to do
these are two little girls if you can't
see this you're just listening to very
[Music]
only nine years old don't flee in the
green buses don't worry the real focus
here has to be on Israel clearly focused
on Israel not on not on jihadism not on
the terror that exists ammas by the way
Hamas Hezbollah Israel's enemies are the
West animes Israel is part of the West
this is what Obama's been spending eight
years doing trying to divide Israel off
from the West so they don't have to
acknowledge that Israel fights the same
enemies because that would destroy
Obama's Obama's belief that Israel is
the great victimizer in the region and
it's true it's a demonstration of just
how disgusting Obama is how disgusting
this administration is I cannot wait for
them to leave in good for Donald Trump
good on Donald Trump Donald Trump
yesterday came out and and openly called
for Obama to veto this thing I'm hoping
that Trump comes out today and threatens
to withdraw UN funding if the if if if
Obama doesn't happen if Obama doesn't
veto this thing but so far all
indicators are that Trump is gonna be
very pro-israel and good for him on that
good for him because who's sort of a
little bit of a Rorschach test during
the election cycle and he's exceeding my
expectations wildly on this and so I
celebrate him for doing that good for a
good for Donald Trump okay so that's
that's as far as we can go with the live
broadcast but if you want to view the
rest of the podcast with a lot more
coming up including the mailbag I'm go
to daily wire coms do that eight dollars
a month will buy you a subscription to
daily wire.com you can also get an
annual subscription that annual
subscription will allow you to get a
copy of my book true allegiance signed
just for you you can frame it put it on
your bookshelf treasure it forever hands
it on to your to your your children and
your grandchildren they can keep it in
the family and a thousand years will be
valuable but you can get it right now at
te wire.com if you subscribe
a lot of great new services coming out
next year they're gonna launch next year
and we can't wait for you to join us
there it's a Lee Weyer comm we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
United States
[Music]